اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من غزه اهلا
بكم في اليوم الت للحرب على غزه قوات
الاحتلال تكثف قصفها المدفعي والجوي على
منطقه الزوايده ومخيم المغازي وسط القطاع
وغارات على مخيم جباليا شمالا وعلى خان
يونس ودير البلح جنوبي القطع ما اسفر عن
عشرات الشهداء والمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي
في غزه يتهم الاحتلال بارغا المدنيين على
النزوح ثم استهدافهم بالقصف
والمجازر اشتباكات وسط وجنوب قطاع غزه
كتائب القسام تعلن تدمير دبابتين شمال
خانيونس وغرب مخيم المغازي وجيش الاحتلال
يعلن مقتل ضابط واصابه 19 عسكريا خلال
الساعات الماضيه والبيت الابيض يقول انه
لا احتمال للتخلص من حماس في العمليه
العسكريه
ويؤكد انها لا تزال تمتلك قدرات قتاليه
كبيره في
غزه تشييع جثمان نائب رئيس المكتب السياسي
لحماس صالح العاروري في بيروت والذي
استشهد في الضاحيه الجنوبيه بعد استهدافه
مع قياديين في القسام واربع مرافقين اخرين
بمسيره
اسرائيليه الى الضفه الغربيه حيث استشهاد
فلسطيني جنوب نابلس قضى برصاص الاحتلال
ولليوم الثاني القوات الاسرائيليه تواصل
اقتحام مخيمي طول كرم ونور شمس وتفجر عددا
من منازل الفلسطينيين والمحال التجاريه
وتعيق عمل اطقم الاسعاف وفي قريه صير جنوب
جنين مقاومون يفجرون عبوه ناسفه محليه
الصنع قرب اليات عسكريه الى اللقاء
n